[Music]
well FBI spying in the 2016 election
could be even more far-reaching than we
already knew trump advisor Michael
Caputo says that in 2016 he and Roger
stone were approached by a man under the
alias Henry Greenberg who asked for two
million dollars in exchange for dirt on
Hillary Clinton Greenberg documents
indicate has also worked as an FBI
informant over the span of 17 years
Bhutto thinks he may have been informing
when he approached the campaign Michael
Caputo joins us tonight
Michael thank you very much for coming
on so this is one of those stories
that's tantalizing because the facts
that we know for certain are seem to
know for certain point right to the FBI
this guy clearly he listed the FBI in an
FBI agent on an immigration application
so he barely was working in some
capacity for the FBI which probably
means he wasn't a Russian government
right right fact we do and and we when I
it was interviewed by the Mahler
investigation on May 2nd I exposed or
answered about this Greenberg approach
in response to a perjury trap and that
really angered my interviewer and his
emotional response was a red flag to me
they seemed to know more about it than I
did so when I got out of my Muller
investigation interview my GoFundMe for
my legal fund went through the roof and
I used some of those funds to hire
investigators in the United States and
Russia to find out more about Henry
Greenberg and we quickly found out
through an Immigration and
Naturalization Service filing that he
made in 2015 that that he signed under
oath saying that he was an FBI informant
for 17 years also here in Iran and in
North Korea and he provided 14 different
FBI informant visas as proof of that so
we quickly dug into every aspect of his
life you can see all of it at Democrat
dossier org Henry Greenberg goes by four
other names he's been in jail ten years
in Russia
committed assault with a deadly weapon
in Los Angeles served time in prison
here and before the FBI had thrown him
out of the country deported him in 2000
but somehow he's back and he's living
under FBI visas and the question isn't
was he an FBI informant the question is
did he take time off from his long
career as an FBI informant to have lunch
off the clock and meet Roger stone
that's the question he's only here
because he's working for the FBI
otherwise they'd have deported him again
so this would be if what you're saying
is true this would be the second
verified instance of the Obama
administration's FBI spying on the Trump
campaign how can you find out if that in
fact was what was happening two
different things also there it's also it
could be proof that this investigation
from the Obama administration began two
months earlier than they're actually
admitting to right now as early as May
instead of July so we understand that
our investigation has emboldened
investigators in Congress Republican
investigators we believe it's very easy
for them if they can get any documents
out of the DOJ to find out if Henry
Greenberg who goes by many other names
Henry o'f Nance Key is his FBI informant
name right if he was under another FBI
informant visa in 2013 she'd find
everyone should it's a joke I don't care
if nobody thinks it's a big deal it was
a big deal Michael Caputo thank you for
that appreciate it